hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on a foreigner again
and the season 10 faction war has just
ended as of today I noticed it was on
stream and I couldn't completely forgot
to make a video today we're gonna be
going over what the rewards are who won
the faction war they probably already
know anyway now I'm gonna give you my
honest thoughts on what this season has
and you know what it's given us for the
faction war and honestly personally
right now I think it's pretty good but
we'll be going a bit more in depth with
that later in the video
so as long as like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I covered the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes that here
updates the petrodes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe the
channel and with that let's get started
with today's video so first up like I
said it is season 10 faction war and
it's just ended and the Vikings have won
I believe they got four out of the five
so I mean everyone knew that the Vikings
were gonna win they win every [ __ ]
season the Vikings came in first the
Knights came in second with one win in
the faction war and the samurai are in
last place because they didn't even get
one this season so but I luck next time
samurai will hopefully get one next
season maybe who knows bug things will
probably still win if you're unaware
with all the faction war works just in
case I have to reiterate just in case
someone happens to not know but if
you're a part of the winning faction you
can use all the stuff that I'm gonna be
showing you in this video for every
character it doesn't have to be just the
Vikings but it is for every single
character if you are part of the Viking
faction hopefully that clears that up
but first we have the outline and the
outline is gonna be changing multiple
colors depending on what faction you are
a part of him which one you ended up
winning so if you're part of the Vikings
you're gonna be getting gold this season
because you guys won if you're part of
the nice faction you'll be getting this
in silver and the samurai are gonna get
bronze because they were in last place
I am only gonna be showing you the gold
version because that's the one that I
have on my account for the Vikings but
you can of course go into your game and
check it it's basically the same just
the colors a bit different but as you
can tell from the top we have a hito
kiri mask at the very top of the design
here with doll heads that she carries
with her on her sides as well that's
gonna be throughout the majority of this
piece and for the majority of the border
it's gonna be some type of rope that's
of course gonna be gold silver or bronze
depending on your faction war placement
it looks pretty good not one of the best
ones in the game but personally still a
good one for me next one is the emblem
and this is for the Knights and Vikings
because it is the top two teams so
samurai are going to be
of luck for this one so Vikings and
Knights if you any and if any of you are
pledged to that faction you'll be able
to wear this emblem on any character
nothing crazy but it's there if you want
it just got a little heat Oh Curie head
like I said nothing crazy but you want
to add a little bit of spice to your
character customization in your fashion
and it's all there and lastly we're
gonna be talking about the ornaments now
like I said before if you're part of the
Vikings you can use these ornaments on
every single character but it's only if
you're part of the Viking faction if
you're part of the Knights like I am on
my xbox account and it or if you're part
of the samurai you will not be able to
use this even though the ornaments I'm
gonna be showing you are for all the
different factions only if you're part
of the Vikings you'll be able to use
these and as well like usual these are
gonna be faction based and the first one
is gonna be the Knights and you're gonna
be seeing a big theme it's gonna be
called the blinking eye and you'll be
seeing a theme of the eyes throughout
all these pieces you're gonna be getting
some wings and feathers all over the
place with this ornament and a lot of
white paint in the middle and then some
eyes all around the piece the Vikings
one is very similar except instead of
having a lot of wings and feathers it
has antlers that actually look very
familiar to shamans ornaments so if you
do like shaman and you're part of the
Viking faction you can actually use this
ornament maybe it has a little bit more
detail and maybe you like this one a lot
more it's kind of best of both worlds
you get the eye stuff in the middle and
then you also get a little bit of the
antler so I think that's a really cool
idea same for the samurai it has eyes
around the ornaments but the variation
in this one is that has octopus
tentacles because of course there is
other than that's a really cool looking
ornament if you don't have any extra
ornaments I'd recommend definitely
putting this one on if you're part of
the Viking faction and lastly we have
the Wulin and yes which is as you can
tell the main theme here is the eyes
that's gonna be all over the place
except there's gonna be waves I believe
on the sides I can't actually tell if
these are waves or something else but
other way looks really cool nonetheless
if I had to give my personal opinion on
what best to worst it would be I'd have
to say Vikings is number one the Knights
are second with the wing samurai have
the tentacles and third and the woman
have the waves at fourth you guys it's
gonna be the end of the beta hope you
guys did enjoy I just wanted to show you
guys a little bit of the faction war
stuff just in case you like one of the
Knights of the samurai ingots see the
ornaments so now you can see what the
ornaments are for all the characters in
satisfaction based and honestly got to
admit seed intends got some really nice
ornaments I'll give it that I actually
like this style I don't know if it's
because the eyes are gonna creep me out
and stuff but I personally do like this
ornament it's really cool so congrats
little bug
the win again you guys have won like 90%
of the seasons so you'll probably get
the next two anyway so congrats to that
yeah like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site or foreign that being
the balance changes the hero updates the
patch notes and the leaks if you want to
be kept up today with everything
happening within the wall the foreigner
and never miss out on an update
definitely subscribe the channel know
that my two most recent videos gonna be
popping up on screen if you guys wanna
check those out we got some stuff to
talk about the recent dev streams yeah
take care guys okay yesterday
you